in this video we'll talk about nmda
receptors or n-methyl d-aspartate
receptors
nmda receptors are one type of
ionotropic glutamate receptors so
obviously they are good they are found
in the glutamatergic synapses it's a
ligand-gated ion channel and it
regulates synaptic strength and
plasticity it is also involved in memory
formation
we'll talk about nmda receptor its
properties and its function in details
so stay tuned till the end of this video
the magnesium ion
is present in the pore of nmda receptor
and that is how it doesn't allow sodium
ion to
get in
generally when glutamate binds sodium
ion should get into the channel
but it is repelled by magnesium block
now the magnesium block is removed when
there is a substantial positive charge
inside the membrane
that kind of repels the magnesium block
and now
the way is clear for the sodium ion to
come in
so this is how
the nmda receptor works
but now let us ask that who is
responsible for the removal of this
magnesium block
and
how the membrane
becomes more positive such that the
magnesium block is removed
now let us zoom into the synapse
and try to understand the functioning of
nmda receptor so here you can see there
is ampa receptors which are another type
of ionotropic glutamate receptors
ampa receptors bind to glutamate and it
leads to sodium influx inside the neuron
after a point of time when sodium gets
in it makes the inside of the
postsynapse positive
and that is why
initially the nmda receptor doesn't open
and it cannot conduct sodium or other
cations but after a while when
substantial amount of sodium gets into
the post-synapse the inside becomes
positive
in this scenario the magnesium is
rippled out
and this block is removed such that the
sodium ions can now easily diffuse
inside the
postsynapse not only sodium ions but
there would be a huge influx of
calcium ions as well
and that is how the nmda receptor works
now in order to understand the nmd
receptors we have to understand its
physiological properties
which can be done by whole cell
recording
so in this patch clamp recording we are
recording in a voltage clamp method
that means the voltage is fixed at a
particular range and now we are
recording the current through it
so let us do a thought experiment
right now we are giving a 70 millivolt
voltage
we are holding the potential at minus 70
millivolts
we see no current
we made it minus 50 millivolts we see
miniscule currents
now at minus 10
there is some amount of current
plus 5 the current direction is now
reverted
and there is substantial amount of
current and the current increases with
the positive voltage
so this is how we can understand the
physiological property but in order to
represent this in a better fashion
people use the iv plot and the gv plot
so the same data can be represented in
the iv plot where we plot current versus
voltage
so as as per our previous slide we can
understand in the negative voltages
beyond minus 50 there was
no current
now
we i mean beyond a point of membrane
threshold
there was current right so in the in
part of the graph here we can see almost
no current at high negative voltage
there is some amount of inward current
at a negative voltage which is beyond
the membrane potential or membrane
threshold
now at a positive voltage there would be
outward current so this is how we can
understand the nmda receptor
characteristics similarly if we look at
the
conductance versus voltage plot we can
also see the conductance of the channel
is almost zero
at negative voltage
so now we understand this particular
graph
in a biological manner
so look at this particular region of the
graph
in this situation what happens is the
membrane is still negative that means it
cannot repel the magnesium ion instead
it is attracting the magnesium ion and
that is why
cations cannot
enter
the postsynapse
look at this portion of the graph in
this situation what happens is membrane
potential is gradually becoming positive
and when it is becoming positive it is
repelling the magnesium ion and thereby
the cations can get inside the post
synapse
so this is how we can explain the iv
curve of nmda receptor
now just to summarize the channel
properties the reversal potential of
nmda receptor is 0 millivolt
it conducts sodium potassium and also
calcium
and the single channel conductance is 50
picoseconds and
it has a sustained uh current properties
that means it conducts for a long time
compared to other ionotropic receptors
even after
end of the particular stimulus
the channel remains conductive
now nmd receptor has multiple subunits
such as nr1 nr2a 2d
nr3a2b
all of these so nmda receptor has
multiple configurations such as
dihetromeric nmda receptor configuration
in this case
at least nr1 receptor subunit has to be
present
and other things could be a combination
of other other
receptor subtypes such as nr2a to b to c
etc or
there could be also
trihedramine nmda receptors where one
subunit
our
would
be
2d
one subunit would be in a 3a to 3b and
another subunit has to be nr1 so nr1 is
the consistent subunit among all of
these
nmda receptors are known as coincidence
detector
that means that detects the coincidence
of pre and postsynaptic activity
in other words the detects the synchrony
between pre and postsynaptic activity
let me explain how
so nmda receptor opening has two
criteria first glutamate binding
and second is the removal of magnesium
block
so glutamate binding reminds the nmda
receptor about a presynaptic event so
glutamate binding only happens when
there is a glutamate release in the
presynaptic terminal so the presynaptic
phenomena is defined by the glutamate
binding
and the postsynaptic phenomena is
defined by the removal of magnesium
block
magnesium block would be removed when
the postsynaptic is active enough
that means the presynaptic activity and
the postsynaptic activity are the
coincidence between pre and postsynaptic
activity is detected at the nmda
receptor level so once this coincidence
is detected there would be a huge influx
of calcium ions inside the post-synapse
and the calcium concentration would rise
from 100 nanomolars to several
micromolars
this dramatic increase in the calcium
concentration would activate several
calcium-dependent kinases such as camk2
which phosphoryl phosphorylates plethora
of downstream targets
and that evokes several intracellular
changes
and it leads to change in synaptic
strength
in one case
there could be potentiation of the
synapse that means the synapse becomes
stronger bigger and there are more
postsynaptic receptors present in this
particular synapse as you can see from
this diagram an nmda receptor plays a
crucial role in this process
nmd receptor blockage can lead to
behavioral defects in mouse
in maurice water maize
a particular platform hidden platform is
placed
near a particular spatial queue in this
case near this particular green spatial
queue
so the when we put the mouse it would
struggle a little bit and then
eventually it would understand that near
this particular green
landmark there is a hidden platform and
next time when we put it it would
straight go to that particular hidden
platform so this is how they learn this
particular task
now this particular memory related task
or navigation task is totally faulty
when we block the nmda receptor by
injecting a nmda receptor blocker
so upon nmda receptor blockage there is
no bias towards one particular quadrant
the mouse spends or find
spend its time to find the hidden
platform in all the quadrant equally it
cannot understand where it where the
hidden platform is
so overall nmda receptor are really
important for memory related tasks
now there are
other aspects where nmda receptors are
involved such as long-term potentiation
let me explain you in a very simple
manner what is long-term potentiation so
let's say we are stimulating this
particular presynaptic yellow neuron
by a stimulating electrode and we are
recording from the postsynapse and we
are getting some post-synaptic potential
like this
now
there is a hundred hertz tetanic
stimulation which is provided to the
neuron and after these 100 hertz
protocol we again put the similar
stimulus
now after putting the similar stimulus
we get a augmented response shown by
this red curve and it is compared to the
previous response in green curve so
obviously this augmented response is
known as potentiation that means the
synaptic
activity or the synaptic strength is
boosted that's why it is giving a
particular response which has a higher
amplitude
one other way of representing this data
is to plot it over time
the slope of these postsynaptic
potential is plotted over time so just
after this tetanic stimulus one can see
that the postsynaptic potential has
increased so the slope has also
increased and the increased slope
persists over time
and it is in order of minutes to hours
so this is a long lasting change in the
synaptic strength which is known as
long-term potentiation but the moral of
the story is if we block nmda receptor
and do this similar protocol
this particular protocol cannot evoke a
potentiated response that means nmda
receptor activity is crucial for this
kind of potentiation or strengthening of
the synapses
so overall in this video we looked at
nmda receptors and how they are
they are one kind of like isotropic
glutamate receptor these receptors are
found in glutamatergic neuron it's a
ligand gated ion channel and they
regulate synaptic strain
they are
we also looked at their
electrophysiological property we looked
how they are involved in memory and
synaptic plasticity so i hope this was
informative if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
like share and subscribe you can get my
social media links and which are linked
in the description so see you in next
video